[Musique]
tout a commencé avec un montage photo
retweeter par julien bayou regardez les
trois listes qui ont fusionné
europe ecologie les verts ps la france
insoumise
il y en a un qui ne soutient pas mais
alors pas du tout la liste d'union de la
gauche en ile de france c'est manuel
valls regardez le tweet de l'ancien
premier ministre
l'alliance des écolos et du ps avec elle
et s'y est une faute politique et une
faute morale
sur tous ces sujets qui sont au coeur du
débat identitaire ou du débat
républicain s'est allié avec cette
gauche là est une faute politique
jean luc mélenchon lui a répondu qu'il
était post franquiste bref on voit tout
ça échange des noms d'oiseaux l'avis de
manuel valls vraiment c'est difficile de
vous dire à quel point ça ne m'intéresse
pas moi je réserve le qualificatif d'
ennemi au front national
je pense que la france a soumise est une
chose et jean luc mélenchon en est une
autre
à longwy et je ne mens pas que quelqu'un
fasse avec son parti je ne suis pas sûre
de son parti soient toujours en phase
avec lui nous ne pouvons pas voter pour
un magma avec les mélenchonistes avec
julien bayou le parti socialiste a perdu
sa boussole républicaine julien bayou
c'est quand même la personne qui nie la
présence de l'islamisme il faut
justement aider les élus de la france a
soumises les militants de la france
insoumise aaron et à se débarrasser de
jean luc mélenchon c'est vraiment une
nécessité carrément pour la
présidentielle pour la présidentielle
pasteur avec lui l'abolition sera le
mieux il va falloir chasser tous ces
cons qui savent pas gérer et qui ose ne
pas voter pour nous vous êtes obligé
c'est votre devoir vous devez changer ça
mais oh
on est où là ils se croient ou les fous
ils me reprochent des propos que je n'ai
pas tenus il parle du rassemblement
national aujourd'hui le rassemblement
national a été remplacé par
le rassemblement national n'est plus du
tout la même formation que le front
national et donc sincèrement j'ai pas
envie de polémiquer avec lui je sais pas
du tout l'impact que ça peut avoir mais
je pense que compte tenu de sa puissance
charismatique son histoire personnelle
il est toujours bon de l'écouter il a
beaucoup de bourse en septembre quand on
a un tel niveau d'abstention c'est ça
veut dire qu'on engage le pronostic
vital de notre démocratie quelque part
premier cas gérald darmanin eric
dupond-moretti ils sont attablés côte à
côte
le ministre de la justice a reproché son
collègue de l'intérieur d'avoir salué
publiquement les bons résultats de son
ex mentor xavier bertrand dans les
autres france le tout s'est passé sous
le regard médusé de plusieurs ministres
gérald darmanin aurait alors répondu à
son collègue et bien commence déjà par
gagner une élection
il ya effectivement une grande
différence entre le rassemblement
national et moi en suisse quand il
s'agit de l'aide alimentaire
je ne demande pas les papiers aux
personnes qu'on aide et si ce sont des
jeunes sans papiers et bah ils auront à
manger et ils auront avec moi à manger
et il faut juste avoir voulu du fer du
en même temps ni gauche ni droite il ya
plus de représentation alors quoi ça
sert de voter puisque il n'y a plus de
choix
on nous avait même pris à démotiver les
français gillot redha fragmenter la
démocratie sur la chambre on va prendre
les choses encore une fois dans l'eau
compréhensible julien bayou vous voulez
répondre parce que là il ya rien de
concret autre face à face il est plus
sur le fond celui là elisabeth bornes
ministre du travail
reprochant sa collègue de la transition
écologique barbara pompili d'avoir salué
la décision du conseil d'état à une
décision qui en fait a suspendu
l'application de la réforme de
l'assurance chômage sur le pas de calais
après un mariage certains convives ont
bloqué une partie d'autoroute pour faire
des tours en lamborghini de location
s'assécher ni en course poursuite avec
la police le chauffard déjà connu des
services de police quitte l'autoroute
mais à cette allure loupé sa sortie et
finit sa course folle dans un
terre-plein